What if writer's block isn't actually a block,
but rather a sign that you're on the verge of
a breakthrough? Most writers, whenever they hit
one of these blocks, try to discipline their way
through it with daily word counts, timers, and
putting your butt in the chair. But that doesn't
work. And I know because I tried it all during a
year-long block that nearly made me quit writing.
What finally got me through it was not
more discipline. It was the opposite.
So in this video I'm going to show you what I
think writer's block actually is, why discipline
makes it worse, and the daily practice that
helped me break through it. And to do that,
I'm going to tell you a quick story about how I
broke through my biggest period of writer's block.
This was during the COVID-19 pandemic and I
was living alone in the Korean countryside.
My university had us teaching online and I was
using my downtime to work on the great foreigner
novel. On paper, these were ideal conditions.
I had a steady paycheck and plenty of solitude,
a stack of books, and my typewriter. I
could essentially do my job in my pajamas.
And so, despite these conditions,
I was completely blocked up. I did
all the productivity stuff — I sat my
butt in my chair from 7:30 to 12:00,
but I just couldn't write. To get through this
block, I really doubled down on the route of
discipline. I thought the problem was me and my
habits. I was reading the James Clear book and
really trying to figure out how to force myself
to write words even when I didn't feel like it.
But what I found is that this approach
makes things worse. What started happening
was I was building up resentment toward the work
because I didn't want to be there. I didn't want
to continue on. Even though I had set myself
this grand project of writing a great novel,
I hated doing the daily work — until one day I
had finally had it. I packed up my typewriter,
put it in the closet, and said: I've had it. This
is enough. I don't want to look at this anymore.
So, if that was a Friday, then it was only two
nights later — Sunday night — I'm lying in bed
and I just get hit with this wave of creative
inspiration. I start getting all these ideas
about the next project that I want to take
on, one that I'm genuinely excited about.
Thrilled about. And the ideas feel like
they're coming out of nowhere. The idea
was to take my teaching online, and that
eventually became this YouTube channel.
It was so out of the blue. You have to think:
I'm a guy who's writing on a typewriter. At that
phase in my life I was very anti-technology.
I had apps and strategies to lock myself out
of social media. I didn't have much
social media. And come to think of it,
at that time I don't even think I had an
account on YouTube. So the idea of building a
personal brand and learning about video — are you
kidding me? — all of this was so foreign to me.
But it was only when I packed up that
project and took it out of sight,
and stopped forcing myself to tend to
this goal that a previous version of
me had set — the version who wanted to be a
novelist and write a great novel — only when
I could finally take that off my table and put
it away did I get hit with this wave of ideas
that at the time seemed quite alien to me,
but has now sustained my creative practice
for five years. It was something that was truly
me. It just didn't match who I thought I was.
And I have to say, this wave of creative
inspiration was almost overwhelming. At a certain
point it was like: okay, enough — I want to think
about this tomorrow. I couldn't turn it off. There
was just so much energy in this train of thought
that I didn't really know how to harness it.
This has only happened to me one other time,
and it was actually more recently — about three
months ago. I did a 10-day meditation retreat.
I've been doing these for a number of years,
so I've probably done 12 or 15 of them by
this point. But on this most recent retreat,
I had a similar experience, and I think in
this case it happened for a different reason.
In the tradition of meditation that I practice,
whenever we do these retreats, it's silence.
No phone, no speaking, no eye contact. So even
though there are other people there, you're not
engaging with others at all. You're completely
self-contained. Unless you need to talk to a
manager about the food or a teacher about your
practice, you're not engaging with other students.
So there I am in the Korean countryside, sitting
in essentially a broom closet — that's the size
of it, it's a meditation cell. And somewhere
around day five or six of this 10-day retreat,
I similarly started getting hit with these
waves and waves of creative ideas. In this case,
it was about things I wanted to do with the
YouTube channel and the website writerscience.com.
The point here is not about the ideas themselves,
but about the conditions that gave rise
to them. So what do these two situations
have in common? And how can you set
those same conditions in your life?
To do that, I need to give you a piece
of psychoanalytic theory that completely
changed the way I understand creativity and
the unconscious mind — because ultimately,
that's where your creativity
comes from. The unconscious.
The basic idea in psychoanalysis
is that we are not a whole,
coherent self — just one self — but
actually, well, Freud would have said
that we're more like two: the conscious mind
and the unconscious mind. Like an iceberg,
you know — we only know the tip, but there's
a deeper layer called the unconscious.
But there's another thinker named Lacan who takes
this a little bit further, and I think this gives
us a really good model for understanding how
creativity works and where it comes from. Lacan
says that the self — human subjectivity — is
actually made up of three different layers,
or registers. He calls them the Real, the
Symbolic, and the Imaginary. The Real goes
to the Imaginary, the Imaginary to the
Symbolic, and the Symbolic back to the
Real. And in the middle there is this force called
*jouissance*, which bubbles up through the Real.
All right, so what does any of that mean?
The Imaginary layer of yourself is who you
imagine yourself to be. It's the self you
see when you look in the mirror in your mind.
It's the story you tell yourself about who you
are and who you're supposed to be. The
Symbolic is your social self — the set
of masks and personas that you put on
to navigate the world and satisfy the
demands that other people put on you. It's your
job, your relationships, and your reputation.
But the Real — to put it simply — is
who you really are behind closed doors.
It's what makes you uniquely you. You could
call this your soul, or your true self,
or however you want to put it. It's the
thing that makes you *you* like nobody else.
But here's the thing: we have these layers
on top of it. We have an Imaginary self,
like an ego — a story we tell ourselves about
who we are that has a kind of consistency.
If somebody asks you who you are, you tell
a story about it, and it has a beginning,
middle, and end and a coherent whole.
The Real isn't like that at all. It's
incoherent. It can't be contained.
It exceeds all bounds and forms.
So you have the Imaginary — the self you see
when you look in the mirror — and then you
have all these masks you use to navigate the
world, your job and your relationships. And
all of these are piled on top of the Real,
holding it down and containing its excesses
so that you don't screw up socially and so
that you don't lose the sense of self you've
cultivated. These things are blocking
you from the source of your creativity.
And I think that's what was happening in my
story. Whenever I was packing up my typewriter,
I was not just clearing room off of my desk.
In a sense, I was killing the Imaginary part
of myself. I'd been carrying this vision of
myself as a novelist for years and years — I
don't even know where I got it — but I was at
a point in my life when that ego was no longer
in service. I know that because in living out
that fantasy, I was not happy. I was miserable.
I didn't feel free. I didn't have a real outlet
to express who I am. And it was driving me crazy.
It was only when I packed it up that I was
able to unleash all this pent-up energy.
It came through. And then I built up a new
image of myself — one who's here teaching on
YouTube — interested in everything that
comes with this completely new genre,
this completely new medium. It only came into
the world when I killed that part of myself.
The same goes for the Symbolic, the social
persona. It was only when I was on the
meditation retreat and separated from all my
relationships that I was able to access this
new wave of creativity. Of course, these things
are necessary — you're not going to just dispense
with them. But sometimes they can calcify.
If we don't allow the energy from the Real
to come up and invigorate these conceptions
of self and these symbolic relationships,
then we can become stuck. And I
think that is what writer's block is.
It's when the energy from *jouissance* is
not able to come up and inform the kind
of persona and the fantasies that you use to
shape yourself in the world. In both cases,
the thing that unleashed this creativity was not
a new discipline routine. It was the ability,
in one way or another, to get out of the way
— to loosen my grip on these constructs and
allow them to be rejuvenated through this
energy that's already pent up inside of me.
Although this might seem pretty inspirational
and easy to do at a theoretical level,
it's not easy in practice. We're actually
very attached to these things. In my case,
I would not have easily dispensed with the idea
of myself as a novelist. And similarly with the
masks we wear in public — to lose that façade,
we have that expression (at least in Asia):
to lose face. It's very painful and
embarrassing to lose face, because that
means you are letting down and disappointing
the expectations that others put on you.
But it's also painful to release the energy
through the Real into these layers — because,
as I said, when I was lying there in bed, these
were exciting ideas I was getting flooded with,
but it was almost too much to bear.
It's very overwhelming. In fact,
that's what these layers are for. They're
protective. These are the floodgates that
hold back the tidal waters. But the cost
of that protection is your creative work.
Which brings me to the point that runs
underneath this entire video: **you have
to let yourself die in order for your work to
live.** Real creativity means letting go of
control — especially control over who you imagine
yourself to be and who others expect you to be.
So if discipline is not the answer to your
writer's block, then what is? And how do you
develop a relationship to the Real and
to your unconscious without forcing it?
If you've been developing a writing
practice for any amount of time,
you've probably heard of all kinds of productivity
routines — from people like Jerry Seinfeld,
who locks himself in a room for whatever it
is, one hour a day, with a rule where during
that time he doesn't need to write, but he's not
allowed to do anything else. No phone, no books,
no music. You just sit there until something
comes. This story gets passed around as advice,
but has anybody ever actually tried
it? Well, I've tried it, folks,
and let me tell you — it doesn't work. I think
it's more myth than actual practical advice.
It probably works for a certain kind of low-value
writing. For emails or reports, I guess it would
work to have a forcing function that makes you do
it. But for creative work that's uniquely yours,
this does not work. Because look at what
you're doing: you're sitting in a room and
trying to force this to come up. And the
unconscious just does not work that way.
All this language around discipline,
when you think about it through this
frame of the unconscious — you realize
that it's just a substitute for forcing the
unconscious. And you simply cannot do that.
It doesn't work. It's your unconscious
calling the shots around here, not you.
The best way to understand this is with the
metaphor of the elephant. You've got an elephant,
and then you've got a rider on top. The rider is
sitting on top of the elephant holding the reins,
and they think they're in control. The
elephant might have good humor — it might
take some suggestions if you guide it
this way and that. But if the elephant
decides that it wants to go in a certain
direction, what are you going to do?
I think this comes up a lot whenever we
pick long-term projects. You decide five
years ago that you're going to write some
fantasy novel or some collection of essays,
and suddenly you feel blocked. Well, I think
that's because you're up there trying to
push the elephant in one direction, but
the elephant is done with that. Every
blocked rider is doing the same thing: they
picked some destination long ago — some book
project or idea of self — and they're trying to
force the elephant to go in that direction. But
whenever you say you have writer's block, I
think it's because you've picked a project
that the elephant no longer wants to comply with.
So here you are sitting on top of the elephant,
yanking at the reins, trying to control
it, and wondering why nothing's happening.
But what if the elephant actually knew better
than the rider? What if the elephant had the
rider's best intentions in mind and
could see a little bit farther? Would
you loosen your grip a little bit, trust it,
and let it take you where it's trying to go?
And what if the place where it was trying to
go was better than the one you had in mind?
The unconscious is working
on your behalf all the time,
even when you sleep. Scientists and
mathematicians call it the night shift,
because there have been so many cases when
a researcher will be working on a problem,
then go to sleep, and the solution
comes to them in the riddle of a dream.
The famous example is the French
scientist Kekulé. He was working
on benzene — he needed to know its shape,
and he just couldn't figure it out. So one
day Kekulé goes to sleep and has a dream
of the mythical snake eating its own tail,
the Ouroboros. He wakes up and suddenly
realizes: *aha, it's a ring.* Kekulé
solved this very important scientific
problem not at his desk, but in his sleep.
But this doesn't just work for scientists and
researchers. Anybody who's played an instrument
knows how this works. If you play guitar or
piano — chime in in the comments if this has
ever happened to you — you start learning a
new song on day one at zero percent. You pick
a section and you practice and you practice,
and after about an hour you get exhausted and
hit your limit. You're not making any more
marginal progress. So you set it down and go
to sleep. Let's say on day one you went from 0%
to 15% — 15% of the song you can now play. Well,
the following day when you practice
that song again, do you start at 15%?
No. You start at like 25%, 30%. You make
progress in the song *in your sleep.*
I don't mean that you're learning notes
you haven't studied before — I'm talking
about the dexterity to perform the song. It
becomes a lot easier to play and a lot more
natural. That's because the muscle memory gets
consolidated and streamlined in your sleep.
You were working on a problem during the day with
your conscious mind, and then your conscious mind
handed it over to your subconscious, which did
its own procedures on it. That's the night shift.
Why do you suppose it is that the unconscious
speaks to us in dreams with mythological snake
shapes instead of just telling us the
answer in plain English? Simply enough,
it's because the unconscious is older than
language. Language came around only about
10,000 years ago, but the unconscious has been
around for millions of years — as long as Homo
sapiens have been around. The unconscious
is the operating system for an animal. If
an animal did not have an unconscious, it would
be a plant. The unconscious existed long before
we had words to think with, and it still
runs underneath every thought that you have.
So whenever you can't reach an idea with this
newest part of your brain — the neocortex,
the language part — the unconscious is still
there working in the background. It just
speaks in a different register: in images,
sensations, dreams, hunches, and itches.
So if you're feeling blocked, this is what
your elephant has been trying to tell you.
The unconscious is not your adversary. It's not
some chaotic force that you have to manage. It's
constantly working on your behalf, solving
problems that the neocortex, this new kid
on the block, couldn't solve itself. It's going
to be composing the sentence you couldn't finish
yesterday, and connecting the two ideas
you'd never thought to connect together.
This, I think, is how I've learned to trust
the elephant — my unconscious. I've learned
through experience that it gives you what
you need precisely when you need it. And
the times in my life when I've just followed
it — call it intuition or grace or whatever
it might be — it has led me somewhere
better than I, in my previous state,
could have ever imagined. We use the
best of our knowledge to make our plans,
but sometimes those plans are lousy because
you don't know what you don't know. The
unconscious is looking out for you and it's
trying to tell you something important.
So if you're blocked on this project
and it's just not letting you through,
maybe just consider: I'm all for goals. I don't
think there's anything wrong with trying to be
more disciplined in your life. But the problem
is taking a discipline approach to what is
essentially a creative endeavor. If you want
to be an artist, you need to learn to listen
to your unconscious and follow it wherever it's
trying to lead you. You cannot summon it. You
can't give it a deadline, and you can't bully
it. You are not going to David Goggins your
way through this book. But the good news is
you don't have to. It's already on your side.
So if the unconscious is working on your behalf,
the only question left is: how do
you give it the room to deliver?
My answer is freewriting. Here's a way to
think about it. If you imagine yourself as
being made up of those three different layers, it
actually looks kind of like a volcano. Below you,
inside, is magma — pressurized and full
of energy, with no shape and no language.
This is the source of your creativity. Freewriting
is the act of pulling a little bit of that magma
to the surface every day. You sit down and just
write whatever comes to mind. No filter, no plan.
You've probably heard something like this before,
but let me clarify a few things. When you do this
freewriting, it's really important not to put
any pressure on yourself to produce something
meaningful. You're not sitting down and doing
freewriting and then trying to adapt it into a
newsletter. You're not freewriting as the first
phase of your essay. I'm not even talking about
first drafts here. What I'm talking about
is dredging up the Real — pulling up this
creative magma within you and just getting
it into language, into a shape. A lot of
which is going to be totally trash. It's not
even "trash" in the usual sense, because you
can't apply qualitative judgments to it
— something is only good or bad against
something you were trying to achieve. If
you're using language like good, bad, better,
worse, you've already missed the point. The
product of this freewriting is not meaningful.
If there's a goal to it, the goal is just to
open up a vent. Because when you're blocked,
it's because these things are
blocking this. What you want is
to open a vent and let a little
bit of this juice out every day,
so it can energize and rejuvenate the images
and symbols we use to fashion ourselves and
our understanding and our model of the
world. You're just letting it breathe.
When the magma hits the page — when what
is bubbling within you gets translated
into language — then it cools into a
shape. Almost like you're dropping the
magma into a bucket. When you drop magma
into a bucket, you don't decide what the
shape is. It's just going to take whatever
shape it takes based on the interaction of
the original source material and the new
conditions in the environment. That's it.
Now, you as the excavator of this magma can
look at that final shape — and of course
you're not going to try to give this
to somebody else; it's not meaningful,
it's not useful, it's just magma. But it
might solidify into a shape that you can
then refine into something that another
person might find useful or beautiful.
When you do this freewriting, it's going to take
whatever form it takes. There's nothing you can do
about that. You can't will it to be prettier. You
can't will it to be more useful. You just drop it
into the bucket, drop it into language, and let
it cool down. Whatever you get is what you get.
But that's fine, because freewriting is not meant
to be meaningful. It's not for anybody — and that
includes you. What comes up is going to look
like gobbledygook, and that's perfectly fine.
If you were a painter, this would be the
equivalent of just moving paint around on
the canvas. This isn't an early sketch of
a painting you're going to do. It's not a
study. Sometimes painters will do that
— little sketches, experiments with the
paint. That's not what we're doing. We are
*playing* with paint at this stage. That's it.
Magma has no coherent structure. It's just full of
energy. The whole point of this practice is just
to get that energy out of the underground and
put it into a form cool enough for you to hold.
Once the magma's cooled — which might be moments
later, or hours later, or days later — then the
analytical mind can come online and you can
read what you wrote and start to sort it out.
You're going to find that a lot of it is dross,
and that's fine. But you're also going to find
certain bits that have a bit of a shine to them,
or what some people say has *energy* — there's
something to it, something you see, something
meaningful, something true, something that you
can work with. As you work with it, you're going
to start to shape it into something you can share
with others — something that's either useful
like a tool or beautiful like a sculpture.
This kind of analysis is where your craft lives.
That's when the manuscript, the newsletter,
the essay, the script — that's when it gets
made. But the sequence here is really important,
because you can't sculpt magma. You've
got to let it cool down. You've got to
let these ideas first percolate inside
of you. You can't force this to come up.
Whenever you do these freewriting sessions,
you just get whatever you're given. The
Greeks wrote about this as being given
gifts from the gods — it's as though
it's coming *through* you. You can't choose
what comes up. You've just got to allow it
to come up and then review it. It's great
if you do this in note-taking software,
because you can use a random note function
to resurface old freewriting scraps. You can
really discover things months or years later
that you didn't see the day you wrote them.
Even if you've never actually done this writing
practice, you already know the difference I'm
talking about. Think about the difference
between two different kinds of conversation.
Sometimes you have a conversation with somebody
and you're just in your head. You're a little
self-conscious, a little dry-mouthed — your
ideas aren't really coming and they're pretty
clunky when they do. And if you do hit any kind
of coherent patch, what you're doing is actually
rehearsing something you've said before. The
other person, whenever this happens, usually
gets a sense like they're being talked *at* rather
than talked *with*. That's a bad conversation.
But then sometimes you just hit a topic that you
really care about and you stop monitoring what
you're saying. The ideas come pouring out
of you, and even though they're new ideas,
they seem to cohere — as though they're coming
up from a unified whole. It's not an old idea
you've rehearsed. It's not a familiar argument.
As teachers, we have these kinds of teaching
routines: you say this, then you say that, then
you insert a joke here. That's not what we're
talking about. Sometimes in a conversation
you just hit your stride and the ideas start
pouring out one by one, and they have a kind of
energy. It's really exciting when this happens.
And every time this happens, it's not because you
planned it to be this way — it's because you got
out of the way. You weren't generating
and judging. You were just letting the
magma rise. Because your unconscious is
always working for you in the background,
it will give you sometimes these ideas that
are entirely coherent, thought through,
easy to articulate, well-argued, substantiated
by evidence and experience — the whole package.
That happens in conversation. And that's
exactly what I'm talking about when I talk
about the purpose of freewriting. It's the
practice that makes that second mode reliable.
Of course, you can never force it. But
by regularly practicing freewriting,
you give it an opportunity to happen. Most
of what comes up is trash — probably 90%
of it. This is magma we're talking about. But
the 10% that isn't is going to be better than
anything you could have planned. That's how
the unconscious works. It knows who you are.
It knows what you're working on and it's
always working for you in the background.
You've just got to get out of the way
and give it a chance to step forward.
The way to do this is to write the raw material
first and then bring your intellect online to
do the shaping and refining. Meaning in these
freewriting sessions is what you end up with —
it's not what you start with. All you need to do
is show up daily, open the vent, let the magma
cool, and trust that the version of you that's
trying to come through has something worth saying.
So there you have it. You're not
stuck. There's just something bigger
in you that's trying to come up. All
you've got to do is get out of its way.